run sites that can give over 30 000
shots a week we've also launched efforts
to get vaccines to pharmacies and
community health centers
and the data shows that we're making
progress
as you can see on our weekly vaccination
progress report
our seven day average daily dosage
administered
is now 1.7 million
average daily shots per day up from 1.1
million only four weeks ago
our seven-day daily average of 1.7
million
compares to an average of 892 000
the week before president biden took
office
that is almost double in just four weeks
throughout this work we're putting
equity front and center
partnering with states to increase
vaccinations in the hardest hit
and hardest to reach communities
increasing supply to convenient and
trusted locations
like community health centers deploying
mobile units
and improving data collection so that we
have a better understanding
of the inequities currently experienced
let me be very clear we have much more
work to do
on all fronts but we are taking the
actions we need to beat this virus
there is a path out of this pandemic
but how quickly we exit this crisis
depends on all of us
that's why i encourage everyone to take
the advice of dr malinsky
dr falchi and dr nunez smith
follow the public health guidance wear
mass
social distance and get vaccinated when
it's your turn
we will do everything we can as a
federal government to defeat this virus
but it'll take all of us stepping up to
do our part
with that let me turn it over to dr
wilinski dr wilinski
thank you i'm so glad to be back with
you today to share the latest
information
on the status of the pandemic let's
first begin with an
overview of the data and then i want to
briefly discuss with you what cdc knows
about recently detected covenanting
variants and what we're doing in
response
covenant team cases have now been
declining for five weeks
the seven day average in the past week
cases have decreased nearly 22 percent
to an average average of slightly more
than 86
000 cases per day similarly
new hospital admissions have been
consistently declining since
early january with a 21 decline in the
seven day average over the past week
averaging approximately 7 700 cases
emissions per day we continue to see the
daily number of reported deaths
fluctuate
the latest data indicate deaths decline
by 0.6
to an average of 3076 deaths
per day from february 9 to february 15th
these numbers are a painful reminder
that we have
of all those we have lost and continue
to lose
our family members our friends our
neighbors and our co-workers
to this pandemic while cases and
hospitalizations continue to move in the
right direction
we remain in the midst of a very serious
pandemic and we continue to have more
cases
than we did even during last month's
last summer's peak
and the continued spread of variants
that are more transmissible
could jeopardize the progress we have
made in the last month
if our if we let our guard down
as of yesterday we have confirmed 1277
cases
of the b117 variant across 42 states
including the first case of the b117
variant with the e4484
k substitution that had previously been
found in the uk
19 cases of b1351 variant have been
found across
10 states of the p1 bearing
has been found in two states
reflective of our commitment to
communicate openly and
often about the latest science on
variance today
cdc is releasing two studies in the
morbidity and mortality weekly report
as well as a commentary in the journal
of the american medical association
on variant specifically in the mmwr
reports
one study describes the different ways
eight people
in soda were infected with the b117
variant that emerged late last year in
the uk
none of the eight individuals had
traveled to the uk
but three of them appeared to have been
infected during international travel to
other destinations
and three during travel to california
one person was exposed to virus in their
home
and another in their community the
second report examined the initial
spread of the b1351 variant in zambia
where the average number of daily
confirmed covet 19
cases increased 16-fold from december to
january
which coincided with the detection of
the be-1351 variant in specimens
collected in december
the b-1351 variant was first detected in
south africa and zambia shares
substantial commerce and tourism
linkages with south africa
which may have contributed to the
transmission of this variant
across the two countries in the jama
viewpoint
co-authored by dr fauci we provide a
synopsis of what we know
about the primary variants circulating
in the united states and the
inter-agency steps the federal
government is taking
to address these variants i know these
variants are concerning
especially as we're seeing signs of
progress
i'm talking about them today because i
am concerned
too fortunately the science to date
suggests that the same prevention
of actions applied to these variants
this includes wearing a well-fitting
mask that completely covers your nose
and mouth
social distancing when around others who
don't live with you
avoiding travel crowds and poorly
ventilated spaces
washing your hands often and getting
vaccinated when the vaccine
is available to you it is more important
than
ever for us to do everything we can to
decrease the spread in our communities
by
increasing our proven measures that
prevent the spread
of cloven 19. fewer cases means fewer
opportunities for the variant to spread
and fewer opportunities for new variants
to emerge
finally a quick comment on masking as i
stated last week
the science is clear consistently and
correctly wearing a mask is one of the
most effective tools we have to spread
stop the spread of coca-19
for reasons supported by science comfort
costs and practicality the cdc does not
recommend
routine use of n95 respirators for
protection against
covet 19 by the general public abundant
scientific
laboratory data epidemiologic
investigations
and large population level analyses
demonstrate that
masks now available to the general
public are effective
and are working and there is little
evidence that
when worn properly well-fitting medical
and cloth masks fail in disease
transmission
cdc continues to recommend the use of
masks that have two or more layers
that completely cover your nose and
mouth and that fits snugly and
comfortably over your nose and the side
of your face
thank you and i look forward to your
questions i will now turn it over to dr
fauci dr patchy
thank you very much dr wolinski i'd like
to spend the next couple of minutes
addressing an issue that we have been
asked about
continually since the successful uh
demonstration of the high efficacy of
the vaccines that are currently being
implemented right now in our country the
mrna vaccines
of pfizer and of moderna and the
question is we do know now that we have
a 94 to 95
efficacy in preventing clinically
recognizable disease but the looming
question is if a person gets infected
despite the fact that they've been
vaccinated we refer to that as a
breakthrough
infection does that person have the
capability
of transmitting the infection to another
person
namely does vaccine prevent transmission
and i had mentioned to you that we
together with the modernity company
and the fisa group is going to do it
also are going to be looking at
the viral load in the nasopharynx to
determine
if in fact a person who's vaccinated but
has a breakthrough infection
compared to a person who's unvaccinated
and has an asymptomatic infection
is there a difference in the viral load
that will be very important
what has happened over the past couple
of weeks is there have been some studies
that are pointing into a very favorable
direction
that will have to be verified and
corroborated by other studies
but let me spend a minute to just
describe it to you
the real question is is there a
relationship
between viral load and transmissibility
we know from
ample studies over many years with hiv
is that there's a direct correlation
between the viral
load that an individual has usually
measured in the blood
and the likelihood that they will or
will not transmit
their infection for example to a sexual
partner the lower the viral load the
less likelihood of transmissibility
the higher the viral load the higher the
likelihood of transmissibility
well when you're dealing with covert 19
you're talking about viral load in the
nasal
pharynx so a study has just come out
about a week
and a half ago from spain that directly
looked at it
with a group of 282 clusters of
infections
and what it showed in a lancet article
that came out on february the second was
something that
we were hoping we would see that there
was a direct
correlation with the viral load and the
efficiency of transmission
very much the same as what we've seen in
diseases like
hiv only now it's in the nasopharynx in
other words
higher viral load good transmissibility
lower viral load very poor
transmissibility
now together with that is another study
that came out on february the 8th on an
online journal which i believe
is worthy of being noted here
even though as i mentioned you want
collaborate cooperation
with other studies it was a study from
israel
it looked at the following question if
in fact you assume
that decreased viral load is due it will
result in a decreased transmission
when you follow breakthrough infections
in the individuals in israel who had
been vaccinated
compared to infections in individuals
who are not
there was a markedly diminished viral
load
in those individuals who were vaccinated
but had a breakthrough infection
compared to individuals
who were not it's very interesting the
israelis were able to do that study it
is noteworthy
that when you look at the amount of
vaccinations
for 100 people namely how many
vaccinations
were given per 100 people israeli israel
is way up there
with 78 doses per 100 people
compared to the united states which is
16.7
doses per 100 people so we have been
hearing and seeing in the press
that israel has a remarkable diminution
in cases associated with the efficiency
of their vaccine
the reason i bring this out to you is
that it is another example of the
scientific data
starting to point to the fact that
vaccine
is important not only for the health of
the individual
to protect them against infection and
disease
including the variants that dr wolinski
has mentioned just a moment ago but it
also
has very important implications from a
public health standpoint
for interfering and diminishing the
dynamics of the outbreak
so the bottom line message is one that
you just heard from dr walensky
that i said the last few times that we
had these press briefings
and that is when your turn to get
vaccinated
comes up get vaccinated it's not only
good for you
and your family and your community it
will have a very important impact
on the dynamics of the outbreak in our
country
and with that i'll hand it over to dr
nunes smith
thank you so much dr fauci um so over
these past
few weeks and i've been um it's been a
great pleasure to be here giving updates
and how we're centering equity in our
response you know spent time describing
the critical need for data in particular
from states and localities
you know to guide an equitable response
and last week
i introduced you to the individuals
selected for the coven 19
health equity task force a group that
will convene to develop recommendations
to inform the work so today just very
briefly
i wanted to zoom out a little bit and
just at a high level describe some of
the elements
of an equitable cloven 19 response that
we've built
and that we are building so far
so in terms of the federal covenant
response we have developed robust
efforts in three key areas on the
continuum of cloven 19
impact and that's vaccination treatment
as well as testing so first vaccination
as we've been discussing so far today
is just critical and the federal
programs
those include the community health
center partnerships retail pharmacy
program
the community vaccination centers and
the mobile vaccination sites
those are being executed to make sure we
also reach
the hardest hit and we're working
directly with state and local leadership
on these programs so second i want to
spend a little time today discussing
equity in cova 19 treatment options
we have been working very closely with
the food and drug administration
to discuss the promise and the potential
of three antibody therapies
authorized for emergency use and in
brief
these therapies have been shown to
reduce hospitalization
and improve outcomes for high-risk
patients diagnosed with copin 19.
you know the potential for these
therapies is especially high
in the communities that have been most
affected by the pandemic
and in fact the 25 locations currently
participating in administration's
rollout
of these therapies include 32 percent of
the american population
and also include significant racial and
ethnic diversity
you know from houston uh to detroit l.a
to atlanta
in coordination with community leaders
in these areas
we have the ability to reach 38 percent
of the black community
42 percent of the hispanic latino
community
and 41 of the asian community in the
country
and we also have reached into rural
populations
so with regard to these therapies in
particular we will continue to keep you
updated
and the third we have been hard at work
developing robust efforts in covid
19 testing as well and so with that i
want to pass it over to my colleague
carol
johnson to describe the latest
developments in the efforts to
streamline and increase
kovid19 testing carol
thank you dr nina smith for your
leadership on testing on equity and on
so much more
i'm really delighted to be here with you
today
i'm carol johnson the coveted response
team testing coordinator
for the last three years i served as a
human services commissioner for the
state of new jersey
providing health care and social
services to our most vulnerable
residents
so when kovac came early and quickly to
our state i experienced firsthand the
difference
access to accurate affordable tests you
can make and slowing the spread
i'm here today because while we're
working around the clock to vaccinate
folks
we also need to continue doing what we
know works to protect public health
and that includes robust testing we need
to test
broadly and rapidly to turn the tide of
this pandemic
but we still don't have enough testing
and we don't have enough testing in all
the places it needs to be
today we're taking a critical step along
that path thanks to brent
president biden's leadership and his
commitment to testing
we're announcing that the federal
government will invest 1.6 billion
dollars
in three key areas supporting testing in
schools and underserved populations
increasing genomic sequencing and
manufacturing critical testing supplies
first we'll invest 650 million dollars
for testing to begin to help schools
with reopening
and to reach underserved populations
while this funding will serve as
only as a pilot until the until the
american rescue plan is enacted
we want to act quickly to help get
support underway in these priority
settings
the department of health and human
services will use these funds to create
regional coordinating centers
that will partner with labs to leverage
their underutilized testing
capacity they'll use that capacity to
support schools
underserved communities and congregate
settings
too often testing can be hard to
implement in non-medical settings
or it can be hard to find the right
partner to make testing work
these coordinating centers centers will
help match lab capacity with demand
from schools congregate settings like
homeless shelters or other underserved
populations
these are places that typically don't
have the resources or the bandwidth to
build partnerships with academic or
commercial testing labs
and that's where the government can be a
facilitator we'll identify existing
tested capacity
match it to an area of need and support
and fund that testing
second we'll invest almost 200 million
dollars to rapidly expand genomic
sequencing to identify track
and stop the coping 19 variants that
we've all heard and talked
much about essentially you know what
sequencing is the process that tells us
which probit variants are in the country
and this surge in funding will result in
a three-fold increase in cdc's genomic
sequencing capacity
to get us to 25 000 samples a week
as a result we'll identify copenhagen
variants sooner and better
target our efforts to stop the spread
we're quickly infusing targeted
resources here because the time is
critical
when it comes to these fast moving
variants
finally we'll address the shortage in
testing supplies
talk to anyone who has focused on covet
testing over the last year
and they'll tell you the same thing our
nation faces a shortage of critical
supplies and raw materials
including pipette tips the specialized
paper used in antigen tests
and the specialized molded plastics
needed to house testing reagents
as a couple of examples so our
administration will invest 815 million
dollars
in building and surging domestic
manufacturing capacity of these critical
testing supplies
we need to build to build the capacity
to produce these materials
or we'll continue to face shortages that
will side track our work in expanding
access to testing
to be clear these resources are a
significant help in the short term
but they are far from what's necessary
to meet the need for testing in
communities across the country
they are merely a reasonable congress
american rescue plan
to fully expand testing and ensure that
any american can get a test when they
need one
with that i'll turn it back over to jeff
well thanks carol and thanks team
i want to emphasize the importance of
testing uh
carol just laid out the case but i just
want to add my two cents here
we have too little capacity for
diagnostic screening and genomic
sequencing
it can take way too long to get a test
and there are too many barriers to
widespread testing and screening
quality affordable testing can be
important to reopening our businesses
and schools and keeping them open and
genomic sequencing testing is how we
will spot variants early
before they spread so we need to make a
significant investment in ramp up
testing across the country
we're using available funds so we can
pilot programs and make progress
but make no mistake we need the american
rescue plan to double
testing capacity promote innovation and
drive down costs for tests
finally before we open it up for q a i
want to make one last point
we know that millions of americans have
lost their health insurance
as a result of this pandemic this week
the administration opened a special
enrollment period
to get more people covered between now
and may 15th
americans can go to healthcare.gov and
enroll in quality affordable healthcare
we encourage people to check out their
options and to take steps to protect you
and your family with that let's open it
up
to questions
all right first up we will go to tamara
keith with npr
thank you so much for taking my question
i appreciate it and
uh the question that i have is for carol
johnson um
as you say there is this really big
problem of a shortage of testing
and many experts say that the us needs a
lot
of very inexpensive paper strip antigen
tests to finally provide
enough testing um you you've mentioned
this money but what else is
being done what are the steps that need
to be taken to finally make that happen
and you know make it so that schools
potentially really could do screening
testing
yeah thank you so much for that question
question what we're doing today
is trying to take what steps we can with
the available resources that we have
but what we need to do is have the
resources that are in the american
rescue plan
to really give us the opportunity to
scale testing it the way we need to do
it
and to build up not only um the testing
itself and the manufacturing capacity
from testing
but the testing services that make sure
that testing isn't just a product but
it's actually a service
and we know how non-medical settings
like schools in other settings
can actually adopt testing and so we
need
a range of options here and we need and
that includes
um easy to use and simple and affordable
options and so that's what we're focused
on with the resources from the american
rescue plan
yeah i'll just add that as as testing
scales when the american rescue plan
resources are invested
that'll both improve the quality of
tests and dramatically drive down the
cost of tests
so that's why it's very important we
make that investment
all right next we'll go to carl zimmer
with the new york times
thank you very much um i have just a
question about the 200 million dollars
for
the genomic surveillance is that could
you talk about where
that initial amount of money is going is
it going specifically to contracts for
private labs
or is there will it be any focus on for
example
trying to get a more representative uh
sampling
across the country in all states
including ones that don't have big
resources of their own
and is there anything going to be done
in terms of the metadata that you
actually need to make sense of these
thank you so carol why don't you start
and then dr wolinski you should also
add your perspective thank you so much
for the question and for raising what is
a key issue which is ensuring that there
is diversity geographic diversity um in
in the collection of these samples so um
the resources really are intended to go
to cdc to help them
ramp up their capacity here in terms of
both what they do and what their
partners do
but with a focus on making sure that we
have that geographic
diversity but i will turn it over to dr
golinski for more
great thank you carol and and you're
exactly right we need geographic
diversity we're partnering with um the
states to make sure that we have
representation from all the states we're
partnering with commercial labs we're
partnering with academia
and we want to expand those partnerships
so so all of those are being done so we
can increase both volume and degree
and geographic diversity and then as you
know it's not just the tests and getting
the test done we need the computational
capacity the analytic capacity
to understand the information that's
coming in
next we'll go to zeke miller with the
associated press
uh thank you for the call uh forgive me
i had a three-parter
first on the uh the latest data uh that
doctor once
did uh is there are are we seeing any
impact of the current
pace of vaccines in terms of the
reduction of new cases or
or yes or when do you expect to see the
impact of the vaccination program
um in the cove in the coven data in
terms of the current cases
um second uh on the genomic sequencing
how long will it take to get to that
25 000 uh sequencing per week uh
you know is that something that you can
turn on in in just a couple of weeks or
is that going to take several months or
even longer
and then finally uh jeff if possible can
we get a status on the
j j vaccine um a lot there's been a lot
of confusion about how much
johnson johnson has ready to deploy
assuming they get the eua
anything along those lines would be very
helpful okay zeke let's start with uh
dr wolinski on the the data question and
the genomics sequencing
yeah thank you for the question um you
know right now we have
um about 54 million americans who have
had
received eight or 54 million shots that
have been
uh given um about five percent of
americans have been uh vaccinated twice
um and so what i would say is we're not
at the place
where we believe that the current level
of vaccination is what is driving down
the
current level disease we believe that
much of the surgical disease happened
related to the holidays related to
travel and so we believe that now we're
coming down from that
so i would articulate really loudly that
if you're relying on our current level
of vaccination
rather than the other mitigation efforts
to get us
to remain low that that we shouldn't
rest in that comfort
we are scaling up vaccination as much as
we can but we are not at a level where
we believe that the vaccination
alone is what's driving the decrease in
in um
in cases right now um in terms of
sequencing we
are scaling up sequencing every day um
when we will get to
25 000 depends on the resources that we
um we have
at our fingertips and um how quickly we
can mobilize our partners i don't think
this is going to be a light switch i
think it's going to be a dial
good on on johnson and johnson um i want
to start by saying that you know johnson
johnson is
at the fda for evaluation right now for
safety and efficacy so it's critical
that we
you know let the fda folks make this
determination which we anticipate will
happen across the next couple of weeks
depending on where they come out we
could have a third vaccine
which would obviously be good good and
welcome news but at the same time we are
ensuring
that both the two eua
approved vaccines moderna and pfizer are
distributed
equitably and fairly and at the same
time we are planning for the possibility
of the third vaccine uh the i think zeke
what you're referring to is that you
know the deal was done with johnson
johnson under the prior
administration and as across the last
few weeks we've learned that there is
not a big inventory
of johnson and johnson there's a few
million doses that we'll start with
the johnson johnson contract commits
johnson johnson to
to deliver 100 million doses by the end
of june
that is more back end loaded we're
working with the company
to do everything we can assuming they
are approved by the fda
to bring forward as much many of those
doses as possible into the earlier
months so i want to be clear that
johnson johnson has a 100 million
commitment for the end of june of doses
at the same time we're going to be
starting with only a few million
in inventory and we're doing everything
we can working with the company to
accelerate the delivery schedule
next we'll go to ed o'keefe at cvs
hey guys how are you um thank you for
doing this again
um two things uh first can you
give us a sense of how the weather
situation especially in texas might be
affecting
vaccine distribution or and testing for
that matter
a lot of vaccine appointments would have
been canceled in texas
uh or other parts of the country
impacted by this winter weather
um how might these areas if you guys
have any sense of it be able to get back
on track
with the rollout and then uh the
president once again talked about the
plan for
k-8 schools last night getting to five
days a week
he was not asked uh as explicitly about
high schools
is there a realistic goal of getting
them open by the end of the school year
or
in your view is that off the table at
this point
let me let me start with the weather um
delays
and then i'll turn to dr bolinsky on
older
students and why that creates greater
complexity than
than younger students you know the
weather's having an impact
it's having an impact on distribution
and deliveries
from from the delivery companies and the
distribution
companies people are working as hard as
they can
given the importance of getting the
vaccines
to the states and to providers
but there is an impact on deliveries and
then as you pointed out ed you know
there's certain parts of the country
texas being one of them where
vaccination sites
are understandably closed and what
we're encouraging governors and other
partners to do
is to extend hours once they're able to
reopen
you know many vaccination sites do
operate 24 7
you know through the weekends through
the evenings
and we want to make sure that as as
we've lost some time in some states for
people to get needles and arms
that our partners do all they can to
make up that last
lost ground consistent with distributing
the vaccine to people as efficiently and
equitably as possible
over to you dr williams great thanks um
so several points with regard to high
schools one is
the science tells us that we know as
children age as they get closer to
teenage years
that they act um in this disease similar
to adults that is they are increased
transmissive they are increased vectors
in terms of transmission
um and that they um are increasingly
sicker compared to younger kids getting
increasingly thicker so
we have to be a little bit more cautious
with our high school kids because
they act differently from from kids who
are really young
that's thing one thing two high school
kids are harder to cohort one of our key
mitigation strategies is to try and have
small cohorts of kids and it's very hard
to cohort high school kids and to
convey and rely on that real high school
experience
of getting you know different classes
and different levels of classes
so that's a little bit more of a
challenge with high school what i will
say
is there are opportunities for in-person
learning in middle school
and in high school through all of our
layer levels of community spread
the most limited which encourages
virtual learning when you're in the red
zone the most community spread
does have opportunities for high schools
to open
um high schools and middle schools to
open if you can follow all the
mitigation strategies
that having been said what we have seen
with the cases coming down
is that while 90 of us jurisdictions
were
in the red zone last week when we spoke
this week with
case is coming down we have about 75 in
the red zone so the less community
spread out there
the more we do to decrease the amount of
disease in the community there are well
more opportunities for
our children to get back to school even
in the middle and high school ranges
i'll just add that you know
doing this smaller class sizes
ensuring they're more school buses
having the equipment and the testing
available
this costs money and that's why the
passage of the american rescue plan the
130 billion dollars for schools is so
important to do it's
so much more expensive than the 130
billion dollars to not have
our kids in school uh in any setting
that is safe
uh and and feasible in this environment
all right last question we'll go to
tommy christopher at media
hi can you hear me now hello
can you hear me yep all right good
uh yeah i have two questions for dr
fauci but obviously any of you can chime
in if you like
uh first of all i'm wondering if you
have done uh
any statistical analysis of how many
teachers or people in teacher households
have died or been hospitalized due to
covid
and have you done modeling for how many
will die or be hospitalized under the
various reopening scenarios and i have a
follow-up
i don't have any information on on that
specifically
um perhaps dr wolenski does from an
epidemiological standpoint but i don't
i have not seen it broken down on number
of teachers who have
died i don't think that's information is
readily available
i might be wrong on that but michelle i
am unfamiliar with data there what i can
tell you is most of the data that we
have from schools
have demonstrated that um and teachers
specifically have demonstrated that when
disease comes into the school is not
because of spread that is happening in
the school it is because
the members who are attending school
teachers staff bus workers and whatnot
bus drivers have have gotten diseased
from the community
not from one another in schools okay and
so
my follow-up question is dr fauci i've
seen you on tv saying that uh
you know you can't vaccinate all the
teachers before you reopen the schools
but i've also seen the president and the
vice president saying look
it's really really important that we
vaccinate teachers and they need to be
prioritized
and so i know you don't have the data
but assuming that the number isn't zero
what do you say to a teacher or the
person who lives in a teacher household
who says you know i don't want to be
the the next or last person to die of
covid because
we were forced to go back to school or
do you say that
your number is zero well well first of
all
let me just uh clarify the issue of
having to get every teacher vaccinated
before
you can really open schools and get
children back to schools that that
really is
rather impractical to make that a scene
of opening to schools at the same time
that we say that
we do say and we feel strongly that we
should try as best as we possibly
can to vaccinate teachers and they
should be
as a high priority within the area of
essential personnel so you definitely
want to make sure that you don't get
that confused even though we don't feel
that every teacher needs to be
vaccinated before you can open a school
that doesn't take away from the fact
that we strongly support
the vaccination of teachers the second
part of your question i think relates to
what dr walensky just said
when you talk about the danger of
teachers getting infected
we know that when you talk about
infection within the school setting
it's what really is going on in the
community that is the risk of infection
to anyone including
teachers yeah what does that mean that
that
if like a teacher gets coveted out in
the community
are they then spreading it to other
teachers in the school because i mean it
sounds to me like
like that wouldn't be very
the data that we have right now and and
rachelle could come in and
and sort of supplement what i'm saying
is that when you see
infections in the school setting
personnel or students
that it is really reflective of what is
going on in the community
not a very special situation of a
particular super spreading
type of a situation in a school that's
not what we are seeing
we're seeing it reflective of what's
going on in the community
let me just add one point of emphasis
here and then we'll close the the you
know the president and vice president
thinks state should ensure teachers
are prioritized which is already being
done that prioritization
um of teachers for vaccinations by about
half the states
in the country teachers should be
vaccinated as dr fauci said like other
frontline workers
and like other frontline workers we
should be grateful for their service
but the president and vice president
agree with the cdc guidelines
that it's not a requirement to reopen
these schools
so with that i want to thank everybody
for for joining today uh
next briefing will be on friday thank